nearly 116 million shots of the
coronavirus vaccine
have now been administered including
enough to fulfill president biden's
promise well ahead of schedule
of 100 million shots in 100 days right
now i think it's day 58
but some republicans are still very
skeptical of efforts to
fight the virus as you can see in this
tense exchange on capitol hill yesterday
between dr anthony fauci
and senator rand paul you want people to
get the vaccine
give them a reward instead of telling
them that the nanny state's gonna be
there
for three more years and you've got to
wear a mask forever people don't want to
hear it there's no science behind it
well let me just state for the record
that masks
are not theater masks are protective
and we asked community there theater if
you already have immunity you're wearing
a mask to give comfort to others
you're not wearing a mask because of any
sign i totally disagree with you
dr anthony fauci joins us now he is
president biden's chief medical advisor
and the country's top expert on
infectious diseases
good morning to you dr fauci so when are
you and senator paul going to lunch
let me just say as the kids of today say
he really seemed to be coming for you
but you can certainly hold your own on
this topic in particular
but were you a little taken aback by his
line of questioning and what is a
message
that you wanted to make sure that we all
hear loud and clear
well i mean senator paul has this
message that we don't need masks which
goes against just about everything we
know
about how to prevent spread of the virus
he was quoting literature selectively
and leaving out
important studies which actually show
that people actually can get reinfected
his point was if that if you're
vaccinated you shouldn't be wearing a
mask
in fact as the more people get
vaccinated just
just put masks away it's theater uh
that's ridiculous i mean i mean
anybody who knows the literature i mean
just the other day
yesterday the day before paper came out
showing
that in individuals who were infected
particularly the elderly individuals
greater than 65
they have a high incidence of getting
re-infected so he was saying if you've
been infected or you've been vaccinated
don't wear a mask which is completely
against all
public health tenants so he's dead wrong
i mean i i don't have anything
personally against him
but he's just quite frankly incorrect
now we should point out that he is an
eye doctor and you were in fa
and you are an infectious disease expert
just saying let's talk about the
astrazeneca vaccine
was pulled in europe and now it's back
on in europe do you know when it's
coming here and
should we be concerned a lot of people
are very worried about this one now
well i think we just need to go with the
data right now it has completed
a randomized placebo control trial in
the united states
the data are currently being examined
at the level of the data and safety
monitoring board i think it's important
for us to hold back any judgment
until we see what the results of the
deliberation
of the data and safety monitoring board
that is assigned
to the trial in the united states there
has been some concern
in the european situation as to whether
or not it was responsible for blood
clots
the european medicines agency the ema
which is the equivalent of our fda
feel there is no direct association that
it has occurred these blood clots but
not to a degree
that was significantly greater than what
would occur anyway
that's their determination i don't want
to make a judgment on that i'd like to
see
what our data show and and that will be
imminent i think we're going to be
hearing about that
in the next few days okay recently
infect infectious disease expert michael
ulsterholm
you know him painted a very scary
picture of the variant that was first
found in the uk and what it could do
here
so when we spoke to him he was talking
about what it could mean for schools
reopening i want you to hear what he had
to say and see if you share the same
concern
there really is a real red flag coming
down
the road i think and that is these new
variants that we're talking about this
particular one from the united kingdom
i think is going to cause such a surge
in cases over the course of the next 14
weeks and i think a lot of schools are
going to be challenged to open it all
what do you think dr fauci well i mean
that's taking
an understandable but somewhat uh
pessimistic
view i think that certainly is possible
michael is clearly uh
you know correct in saying it's a threat
but the one thing that
we need to understand is that the 117
variant which is the one that has
been dominant in the uk and is currently
becoming
more dominant here so in that respect
michael makes a good point
but the vaccines that we use now are
very good in protecting against the 117.
okay so my response would be our
response to that
is two things one get as many people
vaccinated as quickly as you possibly
can and two continue to implement
the public health measures of fast
squaring notwithstanding senator paul
masquering avoiding close contact and
avoiding congregate settings
if we do those two things we can blunt
a potential surge but dr osterholm is
absolutely correct that if we don't do
those things
there is a threat that we will see a
surge coming up yeah i think people need
to constantly be
reminded about the rules and if you've
been fully vaccinated do you need to
still keep getting tested you know not
necessarily
uh in fact i wouldn't say that that's
something that you should do if you're
if you've been fully vaccinated with two
doses of the mrna
or one dose of the j and j i would not
be considered unless
you developed symptoms that were yeah
suggestive of cocaine
but not if you're without symptoms all
right dr anthony fauci always good to
have you here thank you so much for your
time